it is time for this week's
sin city chronicles a weekly look back
at vegas history and happenings
and let's go back to july of 2001
[Music]
it's gonna be my nsync brought their pop
odyssey tour to sam boyd stadium on july
27
2001. the tour was one of the biggest
productions in pop history and that
weekend was all about nsync the guys
they partied at studio 54
after the show and then the following
day held their challenge for the
children charity basketball game at the
thomas and mack
uh-oh steal by justin
it was the pinky and stinky connection
uh justin and britney spears were out
there
it was a star study game yes nsync
britney spears and destiny's child
the band raised 1 million for charity
brittany actually scored some points
that game jubilee opened at the original
mgm grand on july 30th 1981.
the show cost 10 million dollars to get
up
and running that cost included the 1 000
costumes that were needed for the show
for the first six years
they ran shows six days a week two shows
a night
jubilee clothes shop in 2016.
[Music]
on july 31st 1969 elvis presley made his
debut
inside a sold out international hotel
showroom
two thousand fans and celebrities
including sonny and cher
paul anka and priscilla presley were
there for opening night
[Applause]
elvis arrived in las vegas a week before
the show and immediately began
rehearsing five
hours a day the king's original run was
slated for 57 shows
he ended up doing over 630 sold out
[Music]
shows something for everyone this week
metallica
they sold out sam lloyd stadium on july
30th 1994.
the opener that night was candle box and
finally happy birthday
to dana white the ufc president turns 52
this year now would dana ever step into
the octagon
i asked him that question last year
would you ever i mean look at you you're
you're in
physical great shape you're a big guy
would you ever vince mcmahon was 53
vince mcmahon was 53 when he first got
in the ring you're younger than ms
mcmahon would you
ever get in the octagon no no
i battle to get on a treadmill every day
believe me days of me
doing anything are over i
i think i think it'd be great in the
octagon i'd pay to see him fight what
about you jc would you ever get in the
octagon
are you kidding me that match will be
over in two seconds exactly
that's your sin city chronicles for the
last week of july